all right look at this some older
quarterbacks
in the division around four 41 tom brady
and drew brees they play each other this
weekend aaron rodgers at 37
obviously he will take on jared goff at
26 and then it's
all whipper snappers beyond that a wide
range a 19-year window from 43 down to
24
in the division around the playoffs all
right wild card heroes time super wild
card super duper wild card heroes chris
who was the last team to beat the
seahawks in a playoff game in seattle
not including saturday la ranch right
okay
so i know it didn't happen in the
russell wilson era
i remember that correctly i feel like
i i the only game i can remember
i i think is the rams i think the rams
are the last team to beat the seattle
seahawks there in the playoff game
do we have the horn or the wall oh
booyah yeah uh yeah i
was at the game and matt casey you're in
mayor is that the game where like
hasselback had the ball on the four yard
line and tried to throw it in the end
zone
and they dropped it right i kind of
remember that 2004 maybe three
so all right hey mike i'm a historian
just so you know his story well done
thank you
all right um i mean the draft is
wild card heroes right and what yes
better super of a hero with a guy that's
got
a new theme song i mean come on it's
pretty good
giddy up giddy up giddy up josh allen
giddy up giddy up
he's coming for you how josh allen yes
yeah of course i
i mean to me he's the only
listen i know there was a lot of great
individual performances
but his individual performance was the
most to sway a single football game out
of all six games we saw this weekend in
my opinion
you know just again the colts dominated
the time of possession
they ran the ball you know almost 20
more plays on the offensive side of the
ball out gain them in yards third downs
whatever it what whatever it was
the colts won statistically but this guy
right here
josh allen a giddy up uh he just makes
plays
unbelievable i mean just one after
another and every big moment he really
came through for them
to win that football game so he's going
to be my wild card hero
i thought you were going the way look
the bad news is
i now have to hear your new josh allen
theme song repeatedly the good news is
the more you do that one the less i have
to hear any of the others
so it really is well big bad win-win
big ben's dead for the year we won't be
hearing that one anytime soon that's
done for the year or maybe for good
all right uh you don't have a theme song
yet for lamar jackson maybe you should i
know
because i thought that's where you were
going to me that was the first choice
yeah because of the history the two
straight losses in the postseason
the idea that he can't get it done the
idea that he has a hard time coming from
behind
down ten nothing fueled by an ugly
interception that he threw
he ended with 136 rushing yards and
and just a different kind of a guy we
saw regular season lamar jackson in the
postseason
for two straight years we didn't see
regular season lamar jackson
in the postseason and now we have and it
was an amazing
performance from him and from the
baltimore ravens to punch through
to the next round and to get a shot at
their kryptonite super wild card
win means you get to go face your
kryptonite in the kansas city
chiefs although wait a minute that's not
what happened let's go
get your get your game on let's go i'm
thinking the steelers won
i'm still i was so excited by the
possibility of lamar jackson facing his
kryptonite
he won't have to do it until the next
week and actually it works out even
better chris as i try to cover my
mistake
he gets to play the bills a team that
you have been saying
is a horrible matchup buffalo so
giddy up giddy up my butt here comes
lamar
jackson come up with your own damn song
for lamar jackson okay
i am going to come up with a song from
lamar jackson it just has it has to come
to me organically
josh allen just came to me last night
out of nowhere i don't
even know why i put it together uh but
i'm with you
like i wasn't sure who to go with lamar
or josh allen my first pick but i think
they were obviously
the first two picks that was amazing by
lamar jackson
you know the design runs the scramble
touchdown
we hit on some of the throws that won't
be noticed or talked about enough on
on you know highlight shows uh awesome
awesome job by him
all right i think the next one i'm gonna
go to here uh
is darius williams number 31 on the los
angeles rams
had his second year player had a really
good season for the rams he's the other
corner
opposite jalen ramsey so not everybody
knows his name
but damn is he some good football player
and that pick six he had
on the dk metcalf screen pass that was
the game changer that was the point
where you went whoa
10 point lead for this rams defense the
way they look today
russell's going to have to make magic i
mean this is not going to be easy for
them to overcome that
and a day where jared goff you know
credit to him
playing with a broken thumb and all that
no john wolford
the defense was gonna have to win the
game and they looked like they relished
the opportunity
i mean they were all awesome but darius
williams with that pick six that was the
moment where you went
wait the rams are going from oh maybe
they can win and hang on and find some
way to win this game to
whoa i think they're going to win and
russell wilson and company are in
trouble
next one for me i could maybe hold this
one
but i'm going to go ahead and give him
credit as a second round super wild card
hero
leonard fournette of the tampa bay
buccaneer good for you
what when you consider everything he's
gone through this year
when you consider he was available and
the buccaneers signed him
and there have been fits and starts and
he plays and he doesn't play and he was
the third down receiver and then he
wasn't and then he's a healthy scratch
and
on saturday night ronald jones suffered
a quad injury during pregame warm-ups
leonard fernett gets thrust into the
starting role he has 19 carries for 93
yards and a touchdown and the key is he
gave the buccaneers offense the balance
that it needed to avoid doing those
things that have been problematic for
tampa bay all year long where they
spread out the receivers and
and it just doesn't click it doesn't
work the way that
it's supposed to bunch it together run
the ball
set up play action gain some yardage be
more methodical
and fernette with short notice
stepped in as the top guy and got it
done for the tampa bay buccaneers so you
got to give him some credit because by
next week if jones is fine
he's going to go back to being a role
player again yeah i mean you're right
but it was it was it was a great
performance he runs so hard you could
see
i mean when he's healthy and going he's
still a force
he is one of those guys where it's like
oh there's nothing there
but he ran up through the hole so hard
he got three yards and pushed the pile
forward
uh and again they're another team like
if they just run just a little
just to run to keep the defense honest
like you said that's where just brady
and the play action pass are
off the charts um here's what else is
great yeah he's still wearing his lsu
shoulder pads
i know i see that it's not funny to see
the yellow and purple hanging out of the
i know it is crazy well that's football
players it's
it's good luck so they don't he doesn't
want to change it um
my next one i think i'm going to go to
the big boys the big boys
big boys for the baltimore ravens calais
campbell brandon williams i'm going to
give him a little tag team okay mike i'm
cheating
oh i guess we said it's heroes so that's
not you know really the ravens defense
but if you name me like name guys caleus
campbell
brandon williams marcus peters
marlon humphrey holy crap those four you
can't win that game if you don't have
those for it those two being able to
lock down those receivers
you know down the field but really the
first time around the ravens lost the
titans they didn't have
brandon williams and clay as campbell it
just shows you when you got some big bad
jimmies and joes like those guys you
know i don't care what your exes and
those are they're gonna have issues and
they were the big difference in that
football game
all right for me alvin kamara coming off
the couch literally with 99 rushing
yards after he hadn't played in 16 days
as we said last week he's not going to
forget how to play football
but you know the guy was on the covet 19
reserve list he he was
positive for the virus he wasn't able to
practice
showed up sunday good to go got it done
for the saints he'll be even better when
he has a full week to prepare
yeah with tom brady and company coming
to town what a game that's going to be
whoa the saints have beaten the
buccaneers twice
here comes tom brady again no one's ever
beaten him three times in a season and
drew brees has a chance to do it in what
could be drew brees last game if the
buccaneers win
just plenty of great story lines and
again the combined age of 84 for the two
quarterbacks although
brees may be it may be 85 by then i
think bree's birthday is coming up in
the next few days he'll be 85 it'll be a
he won't be 85 he'll be 42. that would
be impressive
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports